oui bonjour c'est pour toi tu les
as juste manqués prends assez de temps
ce gamin il est hystérique tu sais que tu l'as
fait hier il a pris un taxi
jusqu'au Bronx au lieu de le payer il
sort ton badge et il dit
affaire de police
ah un animal oh non  m'a raconté cette histoire
le maire dont j'ai besoin dans mon badge bang
merci beaucoup d'avoir trouvé mon portefeuille et
de me l'
avoir rendu il vient d'avoir un drapeau rouge sur cette
carte de crédit qui était encore allumée ce matin dans
le métro je dois juste utiliser  la chambre du petit
garçon
excusez-moi avez-vous un problème avec
vos cartes de crédit quoi que ce soit ouais je sais que je
tourne beaucoup ouais trois mois peut-être que nous
pouvons nous réunir pour le déjeuner
Félicitations américaines dans combien de temps
pendant trois mois
tu vas être jusqu'au cou dans
couches sales Je suis un voleur à
la tire le père de mon enfant vole des sacs à main de vieilles dames
qu'est-ce que je t'ai dit au
téléphone aucun canapé ne se perd en apportant des
diamants d'or je dois te détester je suis le même gars que
tu as rencontré au bar sauf que j'ai un
différent  travail que vous t  il a pensé et il
me fait juste confiance en ce moment
allez tu te moques de moi
écoute tu sais où trouver Lucy hey
respire ah je ne vais pas accoucher
crétin je ne suis enceinte que de trois mois
maman comment sais tu que c'est le mien  n'en apporte
pas sans ces ah ici comme des diamants
je vais t'apporter des diamants c'est
plus d'un demi-million de dollars en
diamants tout mon monde
Kate boy Bobby je n'ai jamais pris de personne
qui semble avoir moins que moi hé
tu as  Lucy quoi Lucy